Hi, my name is
Andrew Ba Tran, and I'm
a data reporter for
the Washington Post's
investigative team.
And I'm here to talk
about the opioid files
and how we investigated
pharmaceutical companies,
and the government, and
made data accessible to all.
This is a two-week-year-old boy
in an isolation ward in West
Virginia.
Any sound seriously disturbs
him and he won't stop crying,
and that's because he was
born addicted to opioids.
And he is one among
thousands of children
separated from the
parents and families
and forced into state care
by an opioid epidemic that
has fractured families in
every corner of the country.
In West Virginia alone,
more than 5,200 lives
over the past three
decades have been lost.
And we've seen the
effects of this.
We know that the
number of children
in foster care in West
Virginia has doubled ever
since the epidemic started.
And other effects that
we've been able to see
are the death rates in
communities across the country.
In West Virginia, we can see
the effects of the opioid death
rates and we can also
see that there were also
higher rates of child
abuse and neglect claims
in those same areas.
State officials say
that more than 80%
of children in
foster care have been
affected by the drug epidemic.
So we've seen the effects.
We've never really been able
to see the causes before,
not with a lot of specificity.
The thing is, pharmaceutical
companies and the Drug
Enforcement
Administration have been
able to see this
for the longest time
because every single pill a
manufacturer, the distributor,
the pharmacy is
tracked in the dataset
and it's called the automated
reports and consolidated order
system.
And the Drug Enforcement
Administration
is also under the
Department of Justice.
And in fact, because
prescription pain pills are
scheduled-2 drug which means it
has a high potential for abuse,
with use potentially leading
to severe psychological and
physical dependence.
And we call it ARCOS for short.
And so pharmaceutical
companies and the government
have known the
scope of this data
for the longest time, the reach
of the spread of these pills.
And journalists and
researchers have
tried to get this dataset
for the longest time as well.
But we've only been able to
get it at the aggregate level,
maybe by state, maybe by
county, maybe by zip code,
maybe by overall
drug, but we've never
been able to get it at
the raw data set level
where we could really dig
into the nuances of the data.
Every time we've made a request
for it, it's been denied.
That is until recently.
So for context, the
most powerful people
in the pharmaceutical America
didn't want it released.
And a lot of the
most powerful people
in the Department of Justice
didn't want this data released.
However, when 2,000
communities across the US
sued dozens of
big drug companies
over the destruction the
painkillers were causing
across the country,
a federal judge
ordered that the
article's dataset
be made available to those
plaintiffs for examination.
However, they sealed
it away from the public
and from the media.
And so The Washington
Post as well as
the Charleston Gazette Mail
sued for access to that data.
And so we appealed the decision.
And a group of
appellate judges ruled
that the protective order on the
ARCOS data should be amended.
And in fact, they released
data from 2006 to 2012,
and eventually 2014.
And so we got our hands on the
data the day it was released.
And what we found out was
that the dataset was huge.
It had about 42 columns
which isn't too bad,
but it had literally
hundreds of millions
of rows of data for every pain
pill order sold between 2006
and eventually 2014.
And so the team of us, there
are about three data reporters
including myself.
We used a mix of different
statistical analyzing languages
like Python and
R. And so in order
to maintain great
communication between the two,
we used data
structures that could
operate between the two
languages such as Parquet
and Feather.
And because the
datasets were so huge,
we use packages like doParallel
in order to handle all that.
And in order to exchange
our analyses, methodologies,
and reports, we wrote up
everything in Jupyter notebooks
or R Markdown.
I also created Shiny app so that
we could investigate and dig
into pharmacies that
looked suspicious,
because any way you might
slice it would raise
a different set of
pharmacies that might have
set off some suspicious orders.
And so this dataset
was revelatory
because it showed
where each pill moved
from manufacturer to distributor
to pharmacy for the first time.
And so we could see
everything both in
aggregate and fine detail,
and this is what we found out.
We could see that 100 billion
pills saturated the country
between 2006 and 2014.
And pharmaceutical
companies from manufacturers
to distributors to pharmacies
made billions of dollars
a year.
We could finally
see the connection
between the deaths
from opioids and how
they soared in communities that
were flooded with pain pills.
And we saw the highest
per capita death rates
nationwide were in rural
West Virginia, Kentucky,
and Virginia.
And we could see that just
six companies distributed
76% of the pills
during this period.
And we could drill down into
an individual drug companies
and pharmacy companies
like Walgreens,
where we noticed that at
the height of the crisis,
Walgreens sold about nearly
one out of five of the most
addictive opioids, and that
they had a really, really
interesting company structure.
They not only had a franchise
of pharmacies out there,
they also owned the
distribution company as well.
So it was very much vertical
integration all the way.
So while a lot of mom
and pop pharmacies
could argue that
they didn't really
know exactly the impact of
all of the surge in orders
for opioids in their pharmacy,
Walgreens knew exactly how much
and where these
pills were going.
And so we went to the
effort of geocoding
200,000 or so pharmacies so
that we could put on a map
and then really analyze
geographic patterns that way.
And we made it interactive.
That allowed people to
search their local pharmacy
and see the scale
of sales they did
compared to their neighbors.
And so we could really drill
down an individual pharmacies
like this one in Florida.
This is a Walgreens in Florida.
And what's important
to really note
is that it was the law
for these companies
to implement in an
effective system
for monitoring their opioid
sales for suspicious orders.
And so we found
so many pharmacies
that violated those suspicious
orders but kept selling anyway.
This is an example of a
store North of Florida
where starting in 2011,
sales started spiking.
You can see, it's
declined a little bit
after legislators
passed a bill to limit
the sales for a specific
type of oxycodone,
and which slowed it for a
month until customers realized
they could order a different
type of milligrams strength
and get that much easier.
And so that started spiking
even more, exponentially.
It got so bad that a
police chief in that town
make so many arrests that he
wrote a message to Walgreens'
executives, begging them
to change their policies
and to restrict it more, and
to not sell the people who
had been previously arrested for
selling opioids on the street,
and to stop selling
to people who
have been rejected
from other pharmacies
with the same prescription.
But you can see, it
stopped for maybe a month
or slowed down
for about a month,
until it started growing
in sales once again.
And it wasn't until around
2012 that sales finally stop
slowing, started slowing down.
But that was when
they started realizing
that the DEA was investigating
several stores as well
as distribution center.
Until eventually, that
store was suspended.
And then the distribution
center itself
in Florida that
also got suspended,
you can see here that it
sent billions of pills
a month to Walgreens
stores across the southeast
and Florida.
But you can see here,
thanks to the data,
that even though they had
been halted starting in 2012,
that another distribution
center stepped up
to fill those orders that
this particular distribution
center stopped handling.
So Walgreens barely
slowed down their sales.
What was interesting about
this dataset and the story
that we did was that
we made the data widely
available to the public and we
put out explicit instructions
on how to use the data as well.
Because the thing
is, the dataset
was so huge that there was more
stories that we could possibly
tell by ourselves.
And the data could be applied
to specific communities
to see what they thought
was more interesting
and applied to them.
And so in the first
main page where
you could see the results
of the opioid sales
across the country,
there was a section
where folks could
navigate and find
their state and their county,
and see exactly how many pills
were sold there, which were
the top distributors, which
were the top manufacturers,
which were the top pharmacies,
and get the numbers for them.
And not only that, get generated
views specific to their county
and also the summarized tables,
as well as the raw data itself,
if they wanted to do
more deeper analysis.
On top of that, we took that
data and we used Plumber
to create an API out of it.
And what was great
about Plumber is
that with very little
coding, it will self
generate some great
documentation behind this data
portal.
We also created an R
wrapper around it four more
ease, for the special R users.
And then a researcher
at Maryland
saw this and reached out and
went and made a Python package
around this as well.
And on top of that, we created
a bunch of vignettes and walk
tours so that folks could see
exactly how we did our work,
but also figure out
how to tell stories
relevant to their
communities as well.
And we included functionality
in the package to slice
out the data beyond what we had
done in our stories ourselves,
such as being able to
look at individual drugs
and the dataset.
For our stories, we focused
on oxycodone and hydrocodone,
but there are 12 other drugs
in this data set from ARCOS
that we didn't even look at.
The map on the right visualizes
all the methadone sales
in Boston.
It's this area called
Methadone Mile.
And we made it into
a bunch of functions,
include a bunch of functions
that we anticipated
people would find
useful, such as bringing
in the latitude and longitude
for all the pharmacies
that we looked up.
We brought in population
tables for state, county,
and all the years the
data was available so
that folks could
normalize it well.
And also all the
summarized tables,
because it was important
to make data accessible.
It wasn't just enough to
put a dataset on GitHub,
or put a link out there, and
then let people go through it
themselves and figure out
how do it, deal with it,
which researchers
are great at doing.
They can create so many great
research projects around it
such as the effects of the
opioid epidemic on the housing
market, for example.
But we went through the effort
of allowing many doorways
to this data, through the API,
through the browser itself
on that main page,
so that any one
with any level of-- with
different levels of expertise
could access this data.
And sometimes it
can convert others
to R, which I find is a success.
So after we put all
that data out there,
we found out that within a
few days, hundreds of stories
were written by
local journalists,
and it was amazing.
For example, the Cleveland
Plain Dealer looked at the data
and found that there was one
particular small-town doctor
that was responsible for selling
1.6 million pills which helped
fuel the surge there in Ohio.
A radio station, WOSU,
looked at the data
and decided to
focus on the victims
and telling their stories
as all the stories of those
who were left behind.
The Daily Union in
Wisconsin looked at the data
and tracked down the businesses
who are selling the most pills,
and then went to see how
much they had donated
to politicians and to whom.
The Philadelphia Inquirer
made some great interactive
visualizations that showed
how after oxycodone was
reformulated so that it was
not as crushable and snortable,
that the demand for
different types of oxycodone
surged instead.
And through the data,
we were able to look
at manufacturers in a new way.
So while Purdue got all the
attention based on the data,
we could see that they
only controlled about 3%
of the opioid market.
And that three lesser-known
generic drug manufacturers
actually manufactured most
of the addictive pills.
However, since they
weren't well-known,
they avoided DEA's
scrutiny for many years.
Journalists also
saw through the data
that lawmakers were
involved in this.
One lawmaker in
Louisiana, a House member,
owned two pharmacies that
were 12.5 miles apart
from each other in a town
that serves 6,000 people
but sold 1.5 million
pills in that time period.
Another legislator
that journalists
found in the dataset was a state
representative in Tennessee
who was president and CEO of
the largest orderers of opioids
in the state.
And what journalists
connected with that
was that earlier in the year,
this particular state lawmaker,
Shane Reeves,
actually introduced
and helped pass a law
that made it easier
to access opioid prescriptions.
And so as a result of
all this, four companies
that made or distributed
prescription opioids
and played roles and the
catastrophic opioid crisis
have reached a
tentative $26 billion
settlement with counties
and cities that sued them
for damages in the
largest federal court
case in American history.
And internal
documents of all this
showed that the pressure
within the drug companies
to sell opioids were in
conflict with numerous red flags
from the DEA and even
internal workers.
But the profiteers are huge
that sales didn't slow down,
and we're still
feeling the effects
to this day in a different way.
Prescription pain pills were the
main cause of overdose deaths
through 2011.
But then after the laws were
passed, after pharmacies caught
on, after doctors caught on,
and started restricting access
to prescription pain
pills, drug users
then turned to heroin, which
set the stage for fentanyl.
And together, oxycodone,
hydrocodone, heroin,
and fentanyl have killed
more than 400,000 Americans
since the turn of the
century, a quarter of whom
have died from fentanyl in
just the last six years.
So I'm not exactly sure
how to wrap up this talk,
but I want to point out that I
hope the data that should have
been kept an eye on by
pharmaceutical companies,
by the government,
and that's finally
made it into the hands of
the public, the researchers,
and journalists
out there, I hope
we're able to hold
everyone more accountable
so that we can prevent
more foster care children.
Anyway, that's my talk.
Thanks so much for listening.